welcome to those of you who are visiting
today it's great to have you here we're
between that in-between time the week
after exams and the week before
commencement it will look very different
there will be 15,000 white chairs out
there on old campus and there will be
lots of people so go and have lunch
today while the restaurants are empty
it's a pleasure to welcome you here
today and I had planned a sermon that
was going to be very easy but the
scriptures got in the way this would be
a great sunday to devote to the Good
Shepherd this is Good Shepherd sunday we
hear about the Good Shepherd God as the
Good Shepherd in the psalm in those
timeless words that say the Lord is my
shepherd I shall not want we hear of
that God again and first Peter where
Jesus is referred to as the Shepherd and
guardian of your souls we hear of him
again in the Gospel as the gate for the
Sheep as annabelle just read where it
says whoever enters by me will be kept
safe and will come in and go out and
find pasture this would be a good sunday
to spend with that good shepherd we're
all little tired after the semester but
there's a problem in our scriptures
today which as much as I want it to
smooth over it and move on to this word
of comfort as much as I wanted to spend
today in those green pastures beside
those still waters I just couldn't
because there was something I felt I had
to address the problem is 1st Peter
chapter 2 verse 18 if you look in your
worship bulletin you'll notice that our
reading today is first Peter 2 verses 19
to 25 Beverly Stern's read the passage
beautifully and it is in many ways a
beautiful message a message about
enduring suffering first Peter 219 says
it is a credit to you if being aware of
God you endure pain while suffering on
lastly what a word of encouragement for
those who are suffering unjustly but i'm
afraid the church has used this passage
in bad ways over the years i might argue
as to how far we can take this idea of
quiet endurance of unjust suffering but
i think i could work with it it speaks
to courage it speaks to peacemaking it
speaks to hope but the preceding verse
the verse left out of our reading is the
problem and the fact that it's left out
of our reading is a problem for it says
slaves accept the authority of your
masters with all deference not only
those who are kind and gentle but also
those who are harsh this is the problem
the problem is our scriptures our
beloved scriptures the word we pray
should be a lamp to our feet and a light
to our path is saying something we just
can't accept and saying something we
cannot wish or wash away I'd feel better
if I could preach to you about the Good
Shepherd today I'd feel better if I
could say to you yea though I walk
through the valley of the shadow of
death I will fear no evil for thou art
with me thy rod and thy staff they
comfort me but first Peter 218 colors
even these words hearing my Scripture
seem to teach to Christian slaves that
they accept patiently and silently the
abuse the abuses of their masters as
though that was right seems to change
even Psalm 23 now thy rod and thy staff
sound very different imagining the rod
used on another human being how can I
imagine the valley of the shadow of
death without seeing all those slaves
there who died there the scripture is a
problem and digging deeper into its
history this problem only gets worse
because in the history of our own nation
these very vs first Peter two were used
regularly
to justify slavery as God ordained the
way of nature and order and peaceful
society and not only for slaves but
first Peter 2 has been used often to
send battered wives back to their
battered battering husbands with the
instruction to endure silently just as
Christ endured the cross in fact for
anyone suffering in an unjust order bday
slaves or women african-americans or
simply the poor this particular
scripture first Peter 2 and others like
it have been presented by that
oppressive order to say just be silent
God puts you there and that's a history
for which we should lament and from
which we should repent it's a history
across the centuries of Christian
history and especially in America
because of its high ideals that should
inspire in us of vigilance that it
should not happen again we should never
say again to those who are suffering
unjustly God wants you to suffer that's
the way God made the world that's not
the God we know that's not the God we
see especially in Psalm 23 but we should
not let the historical misuse of this
scripture poison it for us because in
context we see that first Peter 2 is
about the early church those very first
Christians who in a time of persecution
when they were despised by the Roman
culture around them as atheists and
aliens how they taught each other to
conduct themselves in that world we have
to read that scripture in that context
first Peter 2 12 prior to our election
today says to all the Christians conduct
yourselves honorably amongst the
Gentiles
so that though they malign you as
evildoers because that's what Christians
were they may see your honorable deeds
and glorify God when he comes to judge
the writer of first Peter is worried
about how this despised minority is seen
by the majority and for their own safety
advises them not to cause trouble the
letter writer wants to justify to the
same Imperial and impressive order that
crucified Jesus that the Christians are
not a threat that's what first Peter 2
is about of course even historically the
author was wrong the Roman persecution
of the Christians only increased after
this was written because there's no
placating a bloodthirsty and oppressive
imperial order as we know as we see in
Syria or Libya today but there's a
difference between how these verses can
be used and that's where I want to go
today one picture I imagine is one early
Christian saying to the other keep your
head down even those of you who are
slaves don't fight back don't draw
attention to us we're in trouble that's
one scene another scene is an American
slave owner of 150 years ago saying read
your Bible you slaves slavery is a
god-ordained institution two very
different ways of looking at this verse
you have to remember that the reason
there were slaves in that early
Christian church is because they wanted
to join the Christian community because
they were excluded from all of roman
culture only the Christians welcomed the
men and even more the slaves came
because they heard in the message of
Jesus a message of liberation of human
dignity of equality and of hope even in
slaveholding America even the same
slaves who heard their masters quoting
the scripture at them
we're still drawn to a faith that was as
they heard it about freedom but how do
we know when we're misusing a scripture
like this one to justify an unjust order
and when a scripture is as Al Gore would
say an inconvenient truth that we cannot
forget when I get stuck on these
questions I have to go back to Jesus
when I worry about what to do with a
hard Scripture like this I have to go
back to Jesus and I think Jesus would
say it's what's in your heart that
matters even as you read and interpret
the scripture what's in your heart is it
fear is it love of your own privilege is
it your comfort in the given way things
are done that motivates your reading of
Scripture if so I think we're wandering
from Jesus's way can't be about fear
can't be about maintaining this order
because we know from Jesus's life that's
not what he taught that's not what he
did that's not who he spoke to I think
Jesus would say that the oppressed get
to be the interpreters of Scripture
those who are hurt most those who are
excluded most those whose rights are
forgotten they get to interpret the
scripture not their oppressors because
jesus said the first will be last and
the last shall be first if I am unjustly
imprisoned I get to say to my fellow
prisoner remember Jesus he suffered even
more than your suffering he died but he
would not lose his faith or his
principles I can say to my fellow
prisoner be comforted in your suffering
but if I'm the warden of that prison I
don't get to say remember Jesus and
except by Authority some would say
suffering can never be God's will and I
would agree if this were the kingdom of
God and God were in charge
but that's not where we are yet in a
sinful world we have to use every way we
have to survive and if that means
connecting my suffering which Jesus is
suffering and that makes it easier for
me to bear I can go with that but I
don't get to tell anyone else that
they're suffering is good or redemptive
or God's will we need to do what we need
to do to survive barbour lundblad one of
my favorite preachers in her commentary
on this passage tells a story about
Howard Thurman many of you know the
great African American author
philosopher and theologian and she
writes this about her picture of how he
might look at the scripture she tells a
story saying that he knew what it meant
to redefine himself and his children in
the face of racism she quotes his
autobiography where he recalls the day
he took his little daughters from Boston
to Daytona Beach where he'd grown up and
Thurman writes this says we sauntered
down the long street from the church to
the riverfront this had been the path of
the church procession the baptismal
ceremony in the Halifax River at length
we passed the playground at one of the
white public schools and as soon as my
daughter's olive and and saw the swings
they jumped for joy look daddy let's go
over and swing this was the inescapable
moment of truth that every black parent
in America at that time had to face what
do you say to your child at the critical
moment of this first encounter I said
you can't swing on those swings why
daddy they asked I said when we get home
and have some cold lemonade I'll tell
you so when we got home and had our
lemonade my daughter Ann had not
forgotten she pressed for the answer and
said we're home now daddy tell us about
the swings
and i said it's against the law for us
to use those swings even though it is a
public school only white children can
play there but it takes the state
legislature and the courts the sheriffs
and the policemen the white churches the
mayor's the banks and businesses the
majority of white people in the whole
state of Florida it takes all these
people to keep two little black girls
from swinging in these swings that is
how important you are I said to my
daughters never forget the estimate of
your own importance and self-worth can
be judged by how much power people are
willing to use to keep you in the place
they have assigned to you you are two
very important girls perhaps we've come
back to Psalm 23 for thou art with me
wherever I am in seasons of endurance in
seasons of revolution wherever we are
placed God is with us and turns the
powers of this world on their heads